all right uh this is from the daily wire
singer lizzo answered critics of her
weight and the fat acceptance movement
during a concert on Friday
yay the rapper formerly known as Kanye
West
we just call him Kanye West I feel like
we just still just call him that I don't
want to misgender but
um Kanye West on Thursday told Fox News
Tucker Carlson that lizzo whom he
considers a friend has been criticized
for losing weight something he found
extremely troubling and tied it to a
larger targeting of black Americans
lizzo told her fans at Toronto's Scotia
Bank Arena I feel like everybody in
America got my mother effing name and
their mother effing mouth for no mother
effing reason
I'm minding my fat black beautiful
business
that's that's what she said everyone's
talking about me I don't know why look
you know there have always been
of course pop stars who uh who are
provocative that's as long as pop music
has existed
it's thrived on that sort of thing you
know publicity stunts and everything
else
but it seems as though in the past
anyway
people who tried to get attention
and then got the attention they asked
for
would then use that attention for
whatever purpose they had in mind or
they would brag about the fact that
everyone's talking about them and how
famous they are you know it was it was
really you know very Brash and showy in
that way
now though we have this game
where they desperately flail around
looking for attention
and then as soon as they get it they cry
that's the process now you know the left
is losing their faith but we're not and
a core part of that faith is prayer I
talk a lot about stressful things all
day and you might feel a little bit
overwhelmed with where the country is
going but I've got good news hallow can
help you find some peace and hope
throughout the day rooted not in the
government or its institutions but in
God hallo has over 5 000 audio guided
prayers meditations and peaceful
Christian music including the rosary
with Bishop Baron and Mark Wahlberg
Bible bedtime stories with Jonathan
roomie who plays Jesus in the chosen by
the way and they've got much more than
that there hello helps you build a daily
routine and a habit of prayer helps me
pray meditate and sleep better it's a
huge part of my daily routine
it will be for you as well if you try it
out it's exclusive three-month trial of
hallow at hallow.com Matt Walsh that's
hello.com Matt Walsh reclaim your piece
in this crazy world download hello today
so the first part of it is not that
different
lizzo now lizzo being morbidly obese
running around naked and everything in
thongs that's not something you saw in
pop music
up until the last few years
but the general thing of just like
flaunting around and and being half
naked and just trying to get attention
oh yeah that we've seen okay so I yes I
we can all agree that that's that's
pretty standard fare
but the next part is not I mean the next
next part strikes me as pretty uniquely
modern
where you desperately desperately
clawing for attention which is all lizzo
ever does she desperately clawing for
attention all the time
okay you don't whether you're morbidly
obese or not you don't walk around in
public and see through outfits unless
you want people to look at you
so when you're when you're going through
your closet and you've got all your
outfits there and you're thinking
yourself well you know I really want to
be Incognito today I don't want people
to notice me I just want to get in and
out I want to run to Walmart I got to
grab a couple things I need some new uh
you know sponges and Windex or whatever
from Walmart and I I don't want to be
bothered
well you're not going to then grab for
the see-through thong in that and on
that occasion
maybe this analogy doesn't really work
that well because it does seem like
that's the sort of thing people do wear
to Walmart all the time but you get my
point generally it seems like if you
don't want attention you're not going to
go with that sort of uh get up and
that's what she does because she wants
the attention
and then she gets it and she just never
stops crying about it
because
that's what the attention is for it's
it's you know you want to generate the
attention
and then you want to convert there's
this conversion process attention on its
own doesn't do any anyone any good you
got to be able to convert the attention
into something
and we live in a in a um in a victimhood
economy and so she converts the
attention into
victimhood tokens
essentially how it works
well I hope you enjoyed that clip from
Matt Walsh show if you did be sure to
subscribe to this YouTube channel and
click the notification button to get
more content like this if you want to
watch or listen to the full show head to
dailywire.com And subscribe today you
can also listen to my podcast on Spotify
Apple podcast or wherever you get your
podcasts